that's just past 10 GMT We Begin this
NewsHour with the sentencing of
Pakistan's former prime minister Imran
Khan to three years in prison the court
handed down its ruling in his absence
for illegally selling State gifts Khan
has now been arrested in the city of
Lahore legal experts say the conviction
may end Khan's chances of running in
elections due later this year let's
bring in our Pakistan correspondent
Kamal Hyder he is joining us live from
Islamabad and this is a big blow to
Imran Khan who's been bogged down by
legal cases hasn't he Kamal what did the
court have to say
foreign
[Music]
Khan and of course his party which is
still one of the most popular parties
within the country I'm outside the
district court which passed that
sentence at about noon which is 7 GMT
within 30 minutes a 30 page document was
released a police team was already
present in Lahore that surrounded his
house and took him and and made the
arrest in Lahore at Zaman park now it
should be noted that his legal team says
that the police did not have a court
order senior lawyers within the country
believe that there are many shortcomings
in this case and that within the next
two to three days he may be released but
it will be important to see whether that
does happen because the government has
already initiated over 150 cases against
the former prime minister tested all his
leadership some of his leadership under
pressure has switched Allegiance and
thousands of his workers are also still
in jail some of them being tried by
military courts so indeed a dramatic
development from the Islamabad District
Court situated behind me absolutely
Kamal it's not the first time Khan has
been taken in by authorities and later
released because courts have said that
that wasn't legal and any time there was
any action taken against Imran Khan
there is a huge reaction given that he
is one of the country's most popular
politicians how are people they're
reacting
well Imran Khan had already
recorded a statement and said he knew
that he was going to be arrested he said
by the time you see this message I will
already be in jail it is up to you now
not to remain silent however it must be
understood uh that when he was arrested
last time on the 9th of May his
supporters came out they were violent
scenes the government said that this was
basically acts of terrorism because
certain military installations were
overrun and that have got led to Serious
charges being brought against him as
well on the 9th of May however thousands
of fish people were arrested some of
them are being tried in military courts
so it is going to be difficult to see
whether there will be a strong reaction
or not I think we'll have to wait and
see so far just a few dozen of his
supporters and lawyers gathered outside
in Residence shouting slogans we're
monitoring the situation but at the
moment we do not expect a major reaction
because the authorities are also ready
to arrest more people if necessary and
say that they will come down hard on
anybody coming out to protest
all right come on thank you very much
for that that's our Pakistan
correspondent Kamal Hyder joining us
live from the capital Islamabad
well let's get more on this now we're
joined by Khalid Yusuf chaudry he is
Imran Khan's lawyer and he's also
joining us live from Islamabad thank you
very much for your time uh firstly what
is your reaction to the court sentencing
Mr Chaudhary can you hear me it's
Elizabeth peranum the presenter here in
Doha can you hear me
yes okay
yes please continue
[Music]
very suggestion in the wrong form of
three years uh simple imprisonment and
000 fine with one hundred thousand five
uh in this case I want to uh tell you
that in this case the right of your
client uh it did not abundance
on many kind of authorities
is
the trial court
did not award the defense side he stuck
down over a right of defense and other
we submit our defense before the
transport that we want to produce some
witness and some evidence in this case
which will
support our
foreign
uh many times we have resubmitted more
than nine okay petitions before the
application
but they were again again demanded that
this this is to uh
visited and on which the trial judges
okay this is
a wise person and we should remove and
in the face should change from this to
any other distribution officer okay so
it certainly sounds like very
complicated proceedings and of course
this is just one of around
150 cases against Imran Khan what is
going to happen to Mr Khan now we
understand that he's been taken from his
home in Lahore where has he been taken
to and what's what's happening to him
uh
[Music]
foreign
criminal case all right
um that is Imran Khan's lawyer Khalid
use of Charles bridge joining us live
from Islamabad we thank you very much
for your time and apologize to the
viewers because the sound quality on
that interview is is not great but thank
you very much for your time